>> ALL SET, HERE WE GO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PLEASE, EVERYBODY HAVE A SEAT.
HAVE A SEAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SIT DOWN, EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT IS GREAT TO BE BACK.
THE PRESIDENT AND DR. BIDEN,
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS AND SECOND
GENTLEMAN EMHOFF, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR HOSPITALITY.
THANKS FOR LETTING US INVITE A
FEW FRIENDS TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE WILL TRY NOT TO TEAR UP THE
PLACE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SOMEONE --
SOMEONE ONCE SAID THAT IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR A FRIEND IN
WASHINGTON, GET A DOG.
OUR FAMILY WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO
HAVE TWO WONDERFUL DOGS, BUT I
WAS EVEN LUCKIER TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO SPEND EIGHT YEARS
WORKING DAY AND NIGHT WITH A MAN
WHO BECAME A TRUE PARTNER AND A
TRUE FRIEND.
JOE, IT IS NOW AMERICA'S GOOD
FORTUNE TO HAVE YOU AS
PRESIDENT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> YOU HAVE GUIDED US THROUGH
SOME PERILOUS TIMES.
YOU'VE BUILT ON AND GONE BEYOND
THE WORK WE ALL DID TOGETHER TO
EXPAND HEALTH CARE, TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE, TO ADVANCE
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND TO PROMOTE
ECONOMIC FAIRNESS.
THANKS TO YOUR DECENCY AND
THANKS TO YOUR STRENGTH.
MAYBE MOST OF ALL THANKS TO YOUR
FAITH IN OUR DEMOCRACY AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE COUNTRY'S BETTER OFF THAN
WHEN YOU TOOK OFFICE, AND WE
SHOULD ALL BE DEEPLY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT, SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TO ALL THE FORMER OBAMA BIDEN
STAFFERS WHO ARE HERE IN PERSON,
SOME OF YOU ARE WATCHING AT
HOME, THANK YOU FOR BEING A PART
OF THIS.
WHEN PEOPLE ASK ME WHAT I MISS
MOST ABOUT THE WHITE HOUSE
YEARS, IT IS NOT AIR FORCE ONE
THAT I TALK ABOUT, ALTHOUGH I
MISS AIR FORCE ONE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S THE CHANCE THAT I HAD TO
STAND SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH
ALL OF YOU, TO HAVE A CHANCE TO
WITNESS SO MANY TALENTED,
SELFLESS, IDEALISTIC, GOOD
PEOPLE WORKING TIRELESSLY EVERY
DAY TO MAKE THE WORLD BETTER.
AND FOR EIGHT YEARS AND EVEN
LONGER FOR SOME OF YOU, I DREW
ON YOUR ENERGY AND YOUR
DEDICATION AND YOUR GOODNESS.
YOU INSPIRED ME, AND I NEVER
WANTED TO DISAPPOINT YOU.
AND I TRIED TO REFLECT THE SAME
HEART AND CHARACTER THAT YOU
DISPLAYED EVERY DAY.
EVEN DURING THE TOUGHEST TIMES,
IT WAS ALL OF YOU THAT KEPT ME
GOING.
SO IT'S GOOD TO BE BACK TO HAVE
A CHANCE TO SEE ALL OF YOU AND
TO ONCE AGAIN SAY THANK YOU.
NOW, AS MUCH AS I MISS OUR WORK
TOGETHER, WHAT'S BEEN A SPECIAL
JOY IS TO SEE WHAT'S HAPPENED
SINCE BECAUSE SO MANY OF YOU ARE
DOING AMAZING THINGS, WHETHER
IT'S IN GOVERNMENT, IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR, IN ACADEMIA OR
NONPROFITS, AND I'M ESPECIALLY
GLAD TO SEE SO MANY OF YOU
SERVING PRESIDENT BIDEN AS WELL
AS YOU SERVED ME.
ALTHOUGH, NOW SOME OF YOU WHO --
LET'S FACE IT, YOU WERE KIDS
BACK THEN, ARE NOW IN CHARGE AND
RUNNING THE SHOW, WHICH IS A
LITTLE SHOCKING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND MAY I ALSO EXPLAIN SOME OF
THE GRAY HAIRS I'M SEEING ON
SOME OF YOU.
BUT IT VALIDATES WHAT I HAD
ALWAYS HOPED, WHICH IS THAT OUR
TIME TOGETHER WOULD ONLY BE THE
BEGINNING OF INCREDIBLY
IMPACTFUL CAREERS, AND SOME OF
YOU WHO I'VE HAD A CHANCE TO
STAY IN TOUCH WITH, I'M THRILLED
TO SEE THAT YOU STARTED FAMILIES
OF YOUR OWN.
I AM A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED THAT
I HAVEN'T HEARD OF ANYONE NAMING
A KID BARACK YET.
>> OR MICHELLE.
BUT THERE IS STILL TIME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
FINALLY, I WANT TO SAY A SPECIAL
THANKS TO THE WHITE HOUSE STAFF.
WE HAD A CHANCE TO SEE THEM ALL
BEFORE HAND.
[ APPLAUSE ]
YOU TOOK INCREDIBLE CARE OF OUR
FAMILY FOR EIGHT YEARS AND ALONG
THE WAY YOU BECAME A PART OF IT,
AND WE HAVE NOT EVER FORGOTTEN
THE KINDNESS THAT YOU SHOWED US.
NOW, WHEN MICHELLE AND I HAD OUR
PORTRAITS UNVEILED AT THE
NATIONAL PORTRAIT GALLERY A FEW
YEARS BACK I SAID THAT AS FAR AS
I COULD TELL, NO ONE IN MY
FAMILY TREE HAD EVER SAT FOR A
PORTRAIT BEFORE.
I CERTAINLY HAD NOT, AND NOW ALL
OF A SUDDEN WE'VE DONE IT TWICE.
BUT THESE PORTRAITS HAVE A
SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE BECAUSE, AS
JOE MENTIONED, THEY WILL HANG IN
THE WHITE HOUSE ALONGSIDE
PORTRAITS OF OTHER PRESIDENTS
AND FIRST LADIES, DATING BACK TO
GEORGE AND MARTHA.
SO IT WAS IMPORTANT TO FIND THE
RIGHT PEOPLE TO PAINT THEM.
I WANT TO THANK SHARON SPRUNG
FOR CAPTURING EVERYTHING I LOVE
ABOUT MICHELLE, HER GRACE, HER
INTELLIGENCE, AND THE FACT THAT
SHE'S
FINE.
JUST SAYING.
SHE IS.
HER PORTRAIT IS STUNNING, AND I
WANT TO THANK ROBERT McCURDY FOR
TAKING ON A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
SUBJECT AND DOING A FANTASTIC
JOB WITH MINE.
ROBERT IS KNOWN FOR HIS
PAINTINGS OF PUBLIC FIGURES,
TONI MORRISON, THE DALAI LAMA,
NELSON MANDELA, MUHAMMAD ALI,
BUT WHAT I LOVE ABOUT ROBERT'S
WORK IS THAT HE PAINTS PEOPLE
EXACTLY THE WAY THEY ARE, FOR
BETTER OR WORSE.
HE CAPTURES EVERY WRINKLE ON
YOUR FACE, EVERY CREASE IN YOUR
SHIRT.
YOU'LL NOTE THAT HE REFUSED TO
HIDE ANY OF MY GRAY HAIRS.
REFUSED MY REQUEST TO MAKE MY
EARS SMALLER.
HE ALSO TALKED ME OUT OF WEARING
A TAN SUIT, BY THE WAY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
HIS WORK IS SO PRECISE THAT AT
FIRST GLANCE IT LOOKS LIKE A
PHOTOGRAPH, AND ROBERT ALSO
PAINTS HIS SUBJECTS LOOKING
STRAIGHT AHEAD, SO IT FEELS LIKE
YOU'RE FACE-TO-FACE FORMING A
CONNECTION, AND THAT APPEALED TO
ME, IN PART BECAUSE PRESIDENTS
SO OFTEN GET AIR BRUSHED.
THEY EVEN TAKE ON A MYTHICAL
STATUS, ESPECIALLY AFTER YOU'VE
GONE, AND PEOPLE FORGET ALL THE
STUFF THEY DIDN'T LIKE ABOUT
YOU.
BUT WHAT YOU REALIZE WHEN YOU'RE
SITTING BEHIND THAT DESK AND
WHAT I WANT PEOPLE TO REMEMBER
ABOUT MICHELLE AND ME IS THAT
PRESIDENTS AND FIRST LADIES ARE
HUMAN BEINGS LIKE EVERYONE ELSE.
WE HAVE OUR GIFTS, WE HAVE OUR
FLAWS.
YOU'VE ALL EXPERIENCED MINE.
WE HAVE GOOD DAYS AND BAD DAYS.
WE FEEL THE SAME JOY AND
SADNESS, FRUSTRATION AND HOPE,
AND WHILE IT TAKES A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF SELF-CONFIDENCE TO BE
PRESIDENT, THERE ARE NIGHTS
WHERE WE LIE AWAKE WONDERING IF
THIS OR THAT DECISION WAS THE
RIGHT ONE.
I'VE ALWAYS DESCRIBED THE
PRESIDENCY AS A RELAY RACE.
YOU TAKE THE BATON FROM SOMEONE,
YOU RUN YOUR LEG AS HARD AND AS
WELL AS YOU CAN, AND THEN YOU
HAND IT OFF TO SOMEONE ELSE
KNOWING THAT YOUR WORK WILL BE
INCOMPLETE.
THE PORTRAITS HANGING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE CHRONICLE THE
RUNNERS IN THAT RACE, EACH OF US
TASKED WITH TRYING TO BRING THE
COUNTRY WE LOVE CLOSER TO ITS
HIGHEST ASPIRATIONS.
AND WHEN FUTURE GENERATIONS WALK
THESE HALLS AND LOOK UP AT THESE
PORTRAITS, I HOPE THEY GET A
BETTER HONEST SENSE OF WHO
MICHELLE AND I WERE, AND I HOPE
THEY LEAVE WITH A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING THAT IF WE COULD
MAKE IT HERE, MAYBE THEY CAN
TOO.
THEY CAN DO REMARKABLE THINGS
NOW, IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE SOMEONE WHO NEEDS NO
INTRODUCTION, MICHELLE WAS THE
BEST THING ABOUT LIVING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND, LET ME TELL
YOU, THE PASTRY CHEFS HERE
DELIVER DELICIOUS PIES ON
REQUEST, SO THAT IS SAYING
SOMETHING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I COULD NOT ASK FOR A BETTER
LIFE PARTNER AND IN MY HUMBLE
OPINION, AMERICA COULD NOT HAVE
ASKED FOR A BETT